far from home wouldn't be the same movie
without its incredible special effects
everything from touching up spidey suits
to creating the elementals required
multiple companies hundreds of people
and hours of work so we'll spend this
video breaking down their additions to
the film and just how incomplete it
would look without them in every
interview when i wear the bubble hat i'm
like
no you didn't
far from home's most memorable scene has
got to be the intense illusion battle
the big midway fight sequence of the
film frame store the company in charge
of the sequence was given an unusual
amount of freedom to create the scene
they weren't given a set script to
follow instead they were given the
creative freedom to come up with the
concepts for the illusions at the same
time they were animating and adding
effects to the shots this gave them the
unique opportunity to provide direction
for the on-set production team for
example with this shot where mj is
attacked by mysterio frame store blocked
out the animation ahead of time with a
cgmj complete with precise lighting from
the moon and lights of the eiffel tower
this rendered footage was passed along
to the set production who were able to
recreate the exact lighting frame store
needed for the shot this allowed them to
slip zendaya's performance into the
final product looking absolutely perfect
by the way the construction site where
the battle takes place 100
cg frame store created the entire
building model adding tom holland's
mo-cap footage on top they used a mocap
suit instead of filming tom and costume
to save time on set all of those reality
bending illusions would have meant way
too many costume changes for just one
sequence that nightmare inducing zombie
iron man utilized mocap as well frame
store went through several designs for
the undead hero finding the right
balance to be horrifying without showing
anything too gruesome the final product
finds a good middle ground resembling a
mummy beneath the broken bits of
machinery
marvel moviegoers are no stranger to the
incredible holograms of this cinematic
universe which means the vfx teams have
to keep their designs consistent with
the marvel style while putting in a few
new twists to keep the visuals from
getting stale for longtime fans for this
scene where mysterio was introduced as
quentin beck and explains the elemental
attacks filming was done using a special
lightbox table rising sun pictures had
to not only design and place the
holograms in the scene but adjust the
lighting and colors depending on which
holograms were showing to make them look
like they were really in the room with
the actors the work had to be done in
layers sometimes completely removing the
lighting from on set
the lighting in the raw footage lacks
the subtle colors reflecting from the
holograms that don't just make the scene
look pretty but create an atmosphere to
complement the actors performances
sometimes an actor's job boils down to
fighting invisible monsters on set the
scene with the water elemental battle
was filmed on set with recreations of
buildings from venice on top of a huge
pool of water and blue screens as
backdrops while the scene utilized a ton
of cg most of the stunts were
accomplished by tom and his stunt
doubles luke scott and greg townley i
never have a strong level it's always me
vfx not only hid the wires required to
help tom jump from pole to pole and volt
onto the rialto bridge but filled in the
backgrounds of venice and of course
brought the water elemental to life
there were no rigs or dummies used for
the monster which means the actors had
to rely on their imaginations to really
sell their performances all of that
water they were drenched with was real
though and very cold
similar techniques were used for filming
the scenes in london while portions of
the scenes set on tower bridge were
filmed on location they also filmed
using set pieces such as the tour bus in
front of green screens the shots
littered with rubble and broken down
cars were set pieces in front of green
screens too for wide shots imageworks
built a complete 3d model of tower
bridge
this model was also used for filming all
the destruction that took place during
the climactic final battle during all
this action we see tons of drones in
various states of despair imageworks was
able to create all of these broken bots
by altering their original models the
drones were constructed out of various
individual pieces all coming together to
form a single machine
like the water elemental the drones
didn't use any objects on set as
stand-ins to help the actors visualize
the scene here's what peter's final
confrontation with beck really looked
like on set
believe it or not this scene set in a
vibrant field of tulips was filmed in an
empty grassland in the uk the jet and
all the flowers were cg
image engine had to simulate an entire
field of tulips with natural wind as
well as the jet landing over 2 million
tulips were simulated in this scene
there were eight colors and eight
different tulips created for each color
in order to render all of them
efficiently they used a method called
precaching where software will download
data ahead of time in anticipation of
its use that way the computers weren't
forced to simulate two million flowers
at the same time stripped of cgi this
scene is just tom holland and john
favreau standing in some grass
did you know imageworks did vfx for all
the previous spider-man movies that's
right they provided effects for the
original trilogy and the amazing
spider-man producers were actually
reluctant to go to them again for the
mcu installments since they wanted to
give the third iteration of the hero a
fresh new look that was until they saw
this test footage imageworks whipped up
to prove that they were up to the task
that's not tom holland in costume that's
completely cg the 3d model looked and
moved so convincingly that even tom
holland himself was fooled to innovate
on their previous work they focused on
making mcu spider-man the most realistic
one yet they did this by studying
imperfections in tom's movements from
unused takes and incorporating them into
the animated spider-man moments of
hesitation or getting caught off balance
helped make the cg spidey feel far more
grounded in reality than any of the
previous films
while some of spidey's suits are
completely computer generated and
require a mocap suit even the costumes
on set require digital tweaking here and
there it can be as simple as removing
wrinkles to keep the suit looking smooth
or adding wear and tear from the intense
action sequences
following in tony stark's footsteps
peter enters the workshop in the back of
the jet to build his own suit for the
first time since he ran around queens in
sweats while the shots of peter entering
are all cg there was also a physical set
for the workshop after filming tom on
set the holograms were added in post
with vfx image engine had to create an
exact replica of the set in order to
accurately layer the holograms and
moving machinery over the real footage
bringing the workshop to life in the
final product
this scene isn't just an important
character moment for peter but a chance
for the audience to see what goes into
building a stark tech spidey suit image
engine had to decide what the individual
elements of the suit would look like
ultimately breaking it down into three
layers for the construction process
there is a white wet fiber layer a layer
of black and red fabric detailing and a
layer for hard surfaces such as the
eyepieces and chest patches the company
in charge of vfx for the final battle in
london imageworks kept these details
consistent when adding battle damage to
the suit if we look at his suit closely
during his emotional reunion with mj we
can see patches of white material where
the suit sustained damage there's a
little like
thing i pull out and then i put a
squeezy tube down into my mouth and then
i can drink from a bottle just how
uncomfortable can wearing a spider-man
suit be every spider-man film has
boasted an extremely vibrant collection
of characters equipped with some
state-of-the-art costumes and makeup
from those tight spidey suits to those
gruesome villainous prosthetics the
stars of the spider-man movies had to
get quite uncomfortable when portraying
their on-screen personas i was just like
swinging about in this super creepy way
and like trying to trying to talk to
peter who wouldn't want to suit up as
spider-man it was our childhood dream to
put on the iconic red and blue suit and
that was no different for star tom
holland i feel like my whole life had
been leading up to me trying on this
suit despite the excitement wearing the
suit on set did come with some setbacks
in fact holland believes that he has the
hardest suit to wear out of anyone in
the marvel universe whenever holland has
the classic suit on he's covered head to
toe in lycra with no skin showing i
can't even use my phone
and i'm 23 like i use my phone a lot in
fact poland isn't even able to scratch
an itch on his face in the costume it's
just one of the costs of being
spider-man it looks amazing it feels
terrible the costume designers behind
the mysterio suit wanted to make sure
that it was as practical as possible
since the bulky costume wasn't
particularly the most comfortable fit
the producers assumed that gyllenhaal
wouldn't want to be wearing the
villain's threads in too many scenes you
know it's like wearing a ball gown they
try to like
you're all of a sudden choked by this
right though gyllenhaal was more than
willing and even a little excited to
bear through the discomfort and wear the
mysterio costume whenever he would see
fit so not only is this costume
practical but he wears it everywhere it
makes sense to wear it so we think this
looks amazing
it took a little bit of time to put on
but once it was on yeah it made me feel
pretty strong it wasn't just alfred
molina who took on the persona of doc
ock director sam raimi wanted the
villain's trademark claws to actually be
practical effects which led to
puppeteers acting around molina to make
his robotic tentacles look more alive
molina needed to do rehearsals in
costumes so he could get accustomed to
moving around in the complicated suit
people understand how much the actors
are doing because you think oh it's all
magical cgi stuff topher grace had to
undergo a grueling makeup process to
become the iconic spider-man villain
venom for the third film in the original
trilogy i had four hours of prosthetic
makeup every morning when i was venom
and just getting on the suit takes about
45 minutes before that so i had to get
there at three or something grace also
had to go through an extensive workout
routine to gain around 20 pounds for the
role
in order for dane dehaan to become the
grotesque and slimy green goblin the
makeup took over three hours initial
designs for the gross looking villain
had dehan taking on an even greener look
as the iconic spider-man villain but the
makeup department decided to go for a
look that felt more slightly human than
full-on goblin that's how i started out
like you know playing pretend and
dressing up as superheroes dane dehaan's
goblin suit weighed 50 pounds and took
an hour to put on the set where de haan
was required to be in his goblin get-up
was over a hundred degrees fahrenheit
and because of the extreme conditions
dehan lost seven pounds in just two days
now that's impressive
jamie foxx had the distinct advantage of
having two distinctive styles as max
dillon aka electro in the amazing
spider-man 2 but it was his villain's
nerdy alter-ego that was internally
painful for typically sleek and smooth
fox fox dubbed his hair on set as the
first black comb over and he also
sported a gap in his teeth when i was
max on the streets girls are like look
at jamie foxx at that hair oh my god
something is off with him at the same
time fox was at least somewhat relieved
that he wouldn't be as bombarded with
attention since he figured there'd be
plenty of people who wouldn't recognize
him honestly though most people would be
able to recognize jamie foxx no matter
the makeup hey y'all tell everybody
electro's in town the makeup department
behind jamie foxx's electro look had to
get very experimental in order to
prevent inhibiting fox's performance as
the blue-skinned villain very thin
pieces of silicone were applied all over
fox's body in order for the look to be
much more believable on top of the
silicone fox had to wear glowing blue
contact lenses it was a great choice to
be in this film and i'm i'm happy and
fortunate that they that they chose
while rhys
full lizard form was mostly cgi there
still was plenty of makeup work to be
done for the transitioning stages of the
villain ifans would spend up to seven to
eight hours in the makeup chair to
complete his green scaly look after
seven hours in a chair with not enough
cigarettes i was kind of in the right
mental state to play a man who was about
to transform into a nine-foot lizard
with a dangerous tail the prosthetics
caused a lot of chafing on ifan's body
which led him to walking around like a
cowboy for several days after filming
after all there has to be some side
effects from becoming the lizard
marvel was extremely strict about what
holland was supposed to wear underneath
his costume during holland's first day
on set he was given thongs by the crew
as the only thing he could wear under
the spiderman costume i had serious
misgivings would my
ever be the same again but i had to get
used to it
secondly i have to wear
essentially pajamas michael keaton's
vulture suit stands out in how it
combines the classic marvel style with
something a bit more grounded i can't
tell you there are hundreds maybe of
little screws literally that special
wrenches made to put the boots in a
certain way a costume this intricate
took quite some time to fully equip on
heaton i don't know what my favorite
costume was because it's like what 7 30.
i'm barely awake i barely know where i
am andrew garfield wasn't necessarily
thrilled the first time he put on his
spider-man suit the suit he wore was
made of a material that was designed to
make you irritated on top of that
garfield's suit was skin tight which led
to more of his body being visible to the
public than we would have preferred one
of the first nights we were out on
location in downtown l.a we were in a
parking structure i knew there were
paparazzi taking terrible unflattering
shots of my you know everything it was
an acting exercise it was just a lot to
uh to hold i i struggled to hold it all
i kind of rejected it a lot rules were
so strict that holland claimed that even
simply drinking water in the spidey suit
was dangerous this led to holland and
the costume designers having to
brainstorm ways to adapt as obviously
holland would need some fluids while
filming in the heat
i can kind of get it i've had a kit kat
in the suit now the left eye on the
spidey costume would have a squeezy tube
attached that holland would have to pull
out and put into his mouth so he could
get a drink of water how refreshing
i loved in spiderman particularly
playing the double roll willem dafoe is
known for his very distinguishable
jawline so when playing norman osborne
in the first sam raimi spider-man movie
he needed to look more like how the
billionaire character looked in the
comics defoe was given dental
prosthetics to make his teeth look
straighter as the main villain though
the prosthetics were removed whenever
his character would look at himself in
the mirror and they were really fun to
do while willem dafoe surprisingly did
not need much prosthetic work done the
acclaimed thespian still had some
discomfort about the green goblin's
technologically advanced costume defoe
called his experience in costume severe
though he still had a great time on set
whenever tom holland put on that
spider-man suit he knew there was no
going back for him in many ways like
having to wait to go to the bathroom an
accident is not an option that suit is
so expensive they'll be so upset with me
in fact holland would have to plan going
to take a bathroom break 45 minutes in
advance hopefully there were no
accidents while filming toby maguire
wore the iconic red and blue spider-man
suit over the course of three films just
because he had a longer tenure as the
character than somebody like andrew
garfield that didn't make the suit any
more comfortable in fact the black
symbiote suit that maguire wore in the
third film proved to be the most
uncomfortable suit of them all it can
ride up in the crotch a little bit it's
not really the outerwear of the suit
it's the inner bit that rides up well at
least it wasn't flash thompson giving
the wedgies this time
toby maguire holds the title of being
the first actor to portray spider-man on
the big screen and with that the costume
designers were still trying to work
through crafting the perfect spider-man
costume in order to get the costume
right the designers had to do a full
body cast of maguire which wasn't the
most fun experience for the actor i had
to stand there for a couple of hours and
then the stuff sticking to the hair on
my body and they ripped it off and it
was extremely painful maguire even
initially had a hard time acting with
the spider-man mask on though he was
able to get used to it quite quickly
while andrew garfield's comic's accurate
spider-man suit may have been a fan
favorite in the amazing spider-man 2 it
was far from comfortable for garfield to
wear it was a very specific experience
and
i imagine um
it'll be different every time garfield
blamed his british reverse on the reason
why he was uncomfortable in the costume
spandex does not suit the british you
are pretty much naked so you have to
trust what you have is enough paul
giamatti's rhino suit required plenty of
cgi but that didn't prevent his on-set
appearance from being an uncomfortable
one in fact giamatti's costume while
filming required him to be attached to a
large metal-like structure some of which
he'd wear with backpack straps
sometimes unscripted moments breathe
more life into a scene the adults are
talking and other times they
are so sorry fall short luckily in the
mcu the improvisation gene is impeccably
strong amongst its actors so in this
video we're taking you through all of
spider-man's unscripted moments that
completely took the films to another
level action we all know tony stark
isn't one to get himself caught up in
emotional moments and in spider-man
homecoming peter parker learned that in
a pretty awkward way after tony stark
has a talk with peter in his car he
reaches over to open the car door but
peter thinks he's actually leaning in
for a hug remember
that's not a hug i'm just grabbing the
door for you
well check out what tom holland had to
say about the scene well that was
actually an improvised moment i think i
just tried to hug him i just thought it
would be funny if i hugged him the
hilarious moment was completely
improvised for laughs but robert downey
jr went along with it speaking about
tony stark and his emotions during the
final moments of avengers infinity war
he was nothing but emotional same mr
stark as spider-man turned into
nothingness in his arms we were all a
puddle of tears when he desperately
chants i don't want to go i don't want
to go spirit please oh you didn't want
to go that was all tom holland again the
director gave him free reign on the
death scene and tom delivered even if he
doesn't think it was that spectacular
himself i don't want to go
three times in a row so it's not that
amazing of an ad-lib it's hard to
believe spider-man is one of tom's first
big roles tom holland and zendaya's
chemistry is off the charts peter parker
and mj are like magic on screen together
and a lot of that is thanks to the
actor's off-screen friendship according
to zendaya tom has a habit of deviating
from the script but thankfully they're
so in tune with one another that she was
able to respond right back no matter how
annoyed she was it just kept improving
he just did not stick to the script he
was trying to throw me off what's your
favorite peter in mj scene
she knows i told her
he didn't tell me i figured it out if
there's one thing better than watching
peter and mj on screen it's watching
peter mj and ned interact with one
another but the truth is a lot of the
time we're watching their off-screen
relationships shine through the camera
remember in spider-man far from home ned
walks in on mj and peter while he's
changing into his spider-man suit the
costume looks great
for the costume party well ned wasn't in
on the fact that mj had found out their
secret and tried to play it off ned's
actor jacob battalion actually said that
was one of his favorite scenes to shoot
because he got to improv all his
comments there was a lot of laughter on
set that day we have to give jake
gyllenhaal credit for playing such a
convincing role as mysterio who knew
that he would actually turn out as a
villain in the end but it looks like we
should be praising jake for more than
just his impeccable acting skills
according to the actor he and director
john watts came up with a lot of
unscripted moments for his character
that ended up in the film we don't know
what specific scenes these moments are
in but let's just appreciate mysterio
for a sec
somebody get this stupid costume off me
having at may be played by a younger
actress in the marvel universe gave us a
whole other perspective on her
relationship with peter it's so
comforting to see the two of them
interact on screen but you'll be shocked
to find out that a lot of their scenes
were unscripted as well one specific
improvised moment in spider-man
homecoming happened while they're eating
in the thai restaurant how many times
you have to say larb before
you talk to me
you know i love you their conversation
was just something the actor made up on
the fly with some guidance from the
director yet again we have another
improvised moment between peter parker
and tony stark this time it's in captain
america civil war check it out
i'm gonna sit here so you move the leg
tony stark telling peter to move over
might seem like it was in character and
it is but it was also robert downey jr's
way of telling tom holland to scoot over
onto his set marker without ruining the
entire take funnily enough it ended up
in the final cut can you even see in
these yes yes i can look i can't
samuel l jackson got his moment to shine
in spider-man as his character nick fury
he even got sassy with spider-man
although the line wasn't even scripted
when peter admits he's a little hesitant
to join their newest plan fury says
[ __ ] please you've been to space samuel
l jackson may not have recalled whether
the line was improvised but jake
gyllenhaal jumped in to confirm it was
100 unscripted i'm here to attest that
was improvised despite his hesitancy
with nick fury peter was all in for
helping out iron man on his avengers
infinity war mission but tony stark
wasn't having it or should we say robert
downey jr wasn't having it while iron
man is having a discussion with doctor
strange peter chimes in that he's back
up i'm back up no you're still away the
adults are talking but that was yet
again another improvised line between
the unscripted heroes tom holland and
robert downey jr spider-man far from
home is full of european landmarks that
make the entire movie stunning even if a
lot of them do get destroyed according
to a screen rant interviewer a lot of
improvising happened in a specific
landmark the london tower the film's
final battle takes place in london and
supposedly during this scene the cast
shot so many versions because of their
ability to improvise you'd never be able
to tell in the final cut they joined
forces like the power rangers you think
you get voltron
voltron you think you're full try drax's
line i'll do you one better why is
gamora is one of the funniest highlights
that came out of avengers infinity war
even if spider-man's life was literally
being threatened in the scene the line
however was actually ad-libbed by drax's
actor dave bautista the rest of the
actors including tom holland are just so
professional that they rolled with it
the camera operator even seemed to be
quick to react michael keaton got some
time to shine in spider-man homecoming
but one of his best lines didn't make
the final cut according to tom holland
keaton actually made a direct reference
to his role as batman in the 80s his
character vulture is a little confused
as to why spider-man would save him and
after tom holland delivers his because
i'm spider-man keaton supposedly
responded but i'm batman we don't know
if the line was part of the script but
tom holland seemed to be hinting it was
ad-libbed like we mentioned before jake
gyllenhaal played the perfect mysterio
and a lot of why his character is so
epic may be because of how well he got
along with tom holland according to tom
mysterio and spider-man were actually
meant to bump heads a lot however while
filming their interactions turned out to
be more friendly the directors decided
to let them head off the script and
build their own relationship between the
characters they basically became bffs
good luck kid i'll give you about a 50
50 chance you're pretty awkward so we
also see spidey's actual bff ned get his
own romantic interest but according to
ned's actor jacob batalon ned's
relationship with betty was basically
developed by him and actress and gory
rice he says they were given a lot of
space for improv they may not have
lasted super long as a couple but
there's no doubt they were adorable i
would totally kiss you but i think i
just threw up in my mouth a little i i
might have a mint it seems like jacob
batalon had a lot to do with all his
characters relationships with the
chemistry between peter and ned we've
never doubted the way they were
childhood best friends and the chemistry
between the actors off-screen is why
it's so authentic apparently because tom
and jacob weren't given the script days
in advance they never knew their lines
which means their interactions are
purely the two actors playing off one
another do you know him too yeah we met
the difference between success
the studio started calling me and gave
me the news and it was all official
yeah it was crazy what kid doesn't dream
about becoming spider-man well for tom
holland that dream became a reality
greetings fellow spidey fans it's hard
to imagine anyone else besides tom
holland playing the mcu spider-man and
it's even harder to see any other actor
or actress playing his family friends
and foes today we'll be taking a look at
behind the scenes of how some of your
favorite spider-man stars got their
roles you know i wanted to get into
movies and this is finally it and it's
crazy that it's
spider-man holland's audition process
lasted a lengthy seven months including
screen tests with both robert downey jr
and chris evans during his test with
downey holland's agent warned him that
marvel preferred that their actors stick
to the script the iron man star ended up
going off script leading the two to riff
off each other holland left the audition
hopeful and even called his mom to tell
her he thought he may have landed the
park six weeks went by which caused
holland to lose hope but sure enough he
was flown back out to atlanta to do a
screen test with evans after weeks of
not hearing back he assumed that he lost
the part until one fateful day when he
saw an instagram post from marvel i type
in marvel
i've still got the article saved on my
computer i did it and it says we would
like to introduce our new spider-man tom
holland i ran downstairs i was telling
my i got it i got it i got the park got
the park
zendaya initially didn't know she was
auditioning for a brand new spider-man
pick with the casting call vaguely
calling for a girl in movie i didn't
even know what kind of character i was
going to play till like i got there and
got to sign this non-disclosure her
auditions went flawlessly holland
recalled that the producers knew right
away that they found their mj she came
in and they cast her before she even
left the room
upon dropping out of college in hawaii
batalon found himself a talent agent who
advised him to join the new year
conservatory for dramatic arts he
initially didn't even have much of an
interest in acting i want to be a
musician at first i when i was going to
college on hawaii i was studying music
theory but then i dropped out and then
acting just kind of happened for me film
school made me really maybe really
appreciate filmmaking during his final
year he did his very first audition
sending in a self-taped submission for a
supporting role in a marvel movie never
thinking it'd go anywhere as faye would
tell batolon received a callback and was
flown out to burbank to perform a screen
test with tom holland batalon described
the audition as nerve-wracking stating
that tom had a really good time but i
was shaking in my shoes but it was
really fun
gyllenhaal has gone on record to say
that it's the character driven films
like donnie darko and nightcrawler that
have attracted him the most when
gyllenhaal received a call from far from
home director john watts about
potentially playing the role of mysterio
he stated that he had to do his research
first to see if it'd be the kind of role
that he's keen on playing that has
always been my desire to find something
in that space that seems to match my
skill and also what i love and my own
honesty and it just so happened that it
does with that part revelry initially
auditioned to play the web head himself
since the casting call was open to any
ethnicity he claimed that while it was
fun he felt like he botched his audition
he would later return to audition for
the role of ned getting called back
multiple times before the producers
realized they had another role in mind
for him flash thompson revolori wasn't
told the name of the character and was
told to recite the lines of biff tannin
from back to the future as a comic book
fan he ultimately put two and two
together and realized that he was
actually auditioning for flash
tomei initially wasn't aware of the
ant-may character in the comics and went
through the entire negotiation talks not
knowing her character was traditionally
depicted as a senior citizen tomei
claims she was horrified upon learning
more about the character she and the
producers initially considered giving
her character her traditional silver
locks before ultimately going a
completely new route with the character
that tomei would be more comfortable
playing
from the time the creative team behind
homecoming decided that vulture would be
the villain they knew right away which
actor they wanted to portray the classic
spider-man foe michael keaton
surprisingly kitten almost wasn't cast
in the role as talks initially fell
through due to scheduling conflicts in
the end keaton did land the part and now
it's hard to picture anybody else in the
role of the winged villain
his audition process didn't last nearly
as long as some of his other co-stars
when it came to being cast as peter's
romantic rival brad davis sent in in
audition tape and there were fake lines
that i'd use so i didn't know what i was
doing and then i just got a call that
said um do you want a role in spider-man
within the span of a week he was flown
out to london to join his co-stars on
set of the blockbuster sequel
harrier revealed that she was simply
just sent the casting call for her
character liz you know you get this
email like spiderman like oh yeah that's
never gonna happen but then i had
another one and another one and then i
had a screen test during this process
she was able to learn more about the
character of liz and how this
incarnation would be different from the
comics upon hearing about zendaya's
casting harrier thought she had lost the
role but a call with her agent reassured
her that she was still in the running
for liz
rice was just coming off her breakout
role in the nice guys upon being cast in
the role she revealed that she was
actually participating in the audition
process for betty brandt while doing
press for the crime comedy
toda like revelry initially auditioned
for the role of ned but after losing the
part the film's producers told her that
they still wanted her in the film
peter's classmate seymour toda noted
that the character wasn't initially
written for a specific orientation but
worked with watts to inject more of her
personality into the character
smooth actually made his marvel debut in
an audi commercial alongside holland and
was able to make connections on set
thanks to his work on the commercial he
soon got a call to being far from home
which he happily accepted
are you okay
i'm fine
linda borg's charisma and great
reputation helped him land the part of
jason he recalls having dinner with
watts with the director telling him hey
when i asked around everyone said that
you were really good to work with the
reason we stopped pursuing other actors
was because people said they didn't like
them
simmons memorably played jay jonah
jameson in sam raimi's original trilogy
but despite it being the same character
kevin feige has made it clear that it is
not the same incarnation feige and watts
even made plans that if simmons turned
the role down that they'd have to
completely reinvent the character it's
great to have the opportunity as these
things evolve to
to be one of the holdovers from from the
previous version
barrick is one of the first openly trans
actors in the mcu he had actually
auditioned last minute but was quickly
cast and was flown out to film in london
he appreciated that his character's
gender identity didn't define his
personality and that he was simply just
along for the ride
audiences around the world have come to
love the cast of marvel studios
spider-man franchise and it's obvious
why the cast has come from all different
kinds of backgrounds giving the films a
diverse point of view it'd be hard for
us to picture a spider-man movie going
any other way who's your favorite actor
or actress from the spider-man films